hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chips website comm so they're going to
be going over a really fun game it
called the Jerome game it I've been
playing quite a bit myself lately and
it's a ton of fun but I'll go ahead and
caution you right now it's not the most
sound gambit it's really meant for blitz
games rapid games maybe you're playing
an opponent far below you as far as
ranking it's gonna catch someone
off-guard if they are not prepared for
it they're gonna have a really tough
time dealing with all the variations
they're gonna have an exposed King and
it's just really hard to deal with that
but if you're playing against an
opponent that is familiar with this
opening and they're really strong player
you're gonna have a really tough time
and you're gonna lose a lot of games
unless maybe it's kind of that blitz
game and you kind of catch them off
guard so this is not me saying that this
is the most sound opening I recognize
that it is not at all but it is super
fun so without further ado we'll go
ahead and get into it it mostly derives
from the gioco piano we start out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6 a
bishop here to c4 and then Bishop to c5
White's going to sacrifice his Bishop
here on f7 and then after the King
recaptures I recognized the king could
not recapture but that would just be
weird that the King comes here to e7 or
even f8 White has a lot of different
options but even just Bishop back here
to b3 is fine up in material the King
can't move or can't castle so that's
going to be bad but we're going to be
looking at the King taking here on f7
the knight taking here on e5 after the
knight recapturing here then the Queen
coming to h5 now from here there's a lot
of ways that black can continue some are
much better for white than others what
we'd really like to see black do is play
King here to f6 or King here to e7 both
of those are going to be easy games for
white we're going look at King here to
f6 always important to know how to
capitalize on your opponent's mistakes
we're gonna play Queen here to f5 now
all of a sudden the Kings can come back
here to e7 we're going to take here King
here to f8 we're going to go ahead and
take this Bishop if you were instead to
play King here to f7 we're going to
first kind of in between move Queen here
to d5 now that after the King moves
we're going to go ahead and play Queen
here to c5 and capture that material but
it may just be easier if
they just go here to f8 save us a move
here from here you can see black played
it few options pawn here to d6 just kind
of retreat back you're in a great
position you're up material your
opponent's king can't castle that's
going to be fine if they play Queen here
to e7 I can't fault you if you take here
like we said before you're going to be
up in material your opponent's king
can't castle it's not as important if
you don't have the Queen on board
because now it just becomes a piece in
the middle that can attack so I usually
like to just keep my Queen back it's a
very aggressive opening so I like to
have all my aggressive pieces but either
way is going to be completely fine third
play Knight here to e7 then I just paid
my queen is not a threat right now I
just play Knight here to c3 continue on
board that's fine King here to f7 that's
always super weird that they want to get
their King involved more into the game
but that's fine if they want to Queen
here to d5 now if they just retreat back
pawn here to e5 this is a nice little
move because if they ever now try to get
their pieces involved pawn here to d6
now Queen here to f3 is just fun because
it kind of blocks off this Knight here
to f6 it's a very annoying pawn right
here on e5 so that's kind of what we see
if we see King to f6 early on into the
game the other move that we really like
to see is the King here to e7 that's
fine we're just first going to take
their night here on e5 that's pretty
easy and then after King's f8 same thing
as we saw before Queen over here to c5
check and if we solve the King over here
to f7 same as before Queen here to d5
check and then we're going to go ahead
and take this Bishop here on c5 now
while those were the best-case moves
you're not going to see them the
majority of the time so it's always
important to know the other options that
you could see one that's very popular is
pawn here to g6 we're going to go ahead
and take here on e5 now Black has one
good move and one good move only if you
don't see this move you should just be
terrorizing them you're either going to
be taking their Bishop you're going to
be taking their rook all these are going
to be very very good for you but the one
move you need to be looking out for is
Queen here to e7 this is the best move
the black has now white has a few
options you could go ahead and exchange
Queens off
bored we're not going to be playing that
game we could play something else you
know pawn here to f4 we're not gonna be
playing that game the game we're going
to be playing is going all-in and that
means Queen taking here on h8 the
Queen's can come down here to e4 and
then King here to a d1 now black has a
few options from here his best moves are
Queen taking here on g2 or Queen to g4
check now both of those are going to be
bad news for us we'll kind of look at
what happens if he does those if you
plays anything else it's going to be
very very good for us but first one that
we'll see is Queen to a g2 we're going
to play Queen takes here on h7 now if
King plays King to f8 this is going to
be very very difficult for white to do
anything except for lose this is kind of
one of those hey your opponents kind of
prepared and you're going to probably
lose but you have a possibility of
saving face a little bit pawn here to c3
your opponent plays Queen takes here on
h1 gobbling up material you play King to
c2 and then just hope and pray that
maybe you can get some sort of
continuous check threefold repetition
and draw the game that's pretty much all
you have to look forward to in this
position now after we have the Queen
taking here at h7 if he doesn't come to
f8 he has a few other options if you
were to play King to f6
okay well then all of a sudden we're
going to play Queen to h8 maybe we can
continue this on board that's going to
be fine for us if we get a threefold
repetition and get a draw on board we'll
take that all day long if he ever goes
over here to king D 6 if we ever see
King e6 for bringing our work over here
to e1 that's going to be fine we're
getting more pressure controlling this
efile check now we can start to get our
queen involved into the game potentially
wherever he goes we can get our knight
involved we can play pawn here to d4 it
doesn't matter if they take we can get
our dark square Bishop welcome to the
game so that's definitely going to be
very good could always play the terrible
move of just King to be 8 and then just
capture here you know we could see the
bishop come up we
could see the king come down here and
then we can get our rook involved into
the game so that's going to be very very
good for white now if we come back
instead of the Queen taking on g2 the
other move we really don't want to see
is Queen to g4 but it's not as bad but
we'll play pawn here to f3 stopping that
Queen here to g2 and then we're kind of
the song the same song and dance Queen
here to h7 and then kind of hoping for
the same stuff now if we don't see the
Queen move
we could see some other moves Knight to
f6 sounds reasonable
pawn here to f3 this is important move
on the board now the the Queen's gonna
have to move so we could see Queen to e5
potentially and then d3 this is a much
better position on board it's going to
be very difficult for black to actually
attack with these pawns right here so
that's going to be good now if we come
back and say okay let's say the the
knight doesn't move but let's say pawn
to d5 sometimes players really trying to
control the center of the board they
feel like they've already got it right
now so they want to open up the door for
their LightSquared Bishop involved into
the game because Hey once you get your
Bishop here it's going to be very very
difficult potentially this is going to
be great for black we play Queen to h7
now it doesn't even matter if they play
King to FA because we can have pawn to
f3 first before the Queen takes here on
g2 and this is going to be a very very
good game for white so that's kind of
what we're going to see if the pawn
comes here to g6 early on in the gambit
next move that you may see is Knight to
g6 just kind of blocking this go don't
right away take this fish up here on c5
first go ahead and play Queen to d5 he
potentially could just come here to f8
and then we take this Bishop but now
it's checked so that's going to be
better for us I could always play King
to e8 that's fine as well we take this
Bishop here on c5 now you may see pawn
to d6 if there's a few ways you can play
this I like to just continue the
aggression Queen here to b5 just giving
them more opportunities to makes
mistakes it's more correct to play pawn
here to c6 but potentially they could
play Bishop here to DC
seven all of a sudden Queen here to be
seven this is going to be better just
gobbling up more material on board so
definitely try that if you see it now if
we come back here instead of the knight
coming here we could see a few other
options we're going to go over some of
them the strongest move for black is
King to e6 now the reason you won't see
it as much as you should is it feels
counterintuitive for black to be
bringing his King to the center of the
board and feeling like that's the best
move now if they've studied it and they
understand how black should be defending
and you know they're a strong player if
they play King to e6 that's probably a
bad sign because they know how to defend
but usually if you're not too familiar
it's just very scary to go ahead and
play this King here to e6 but from here
why it's going to play pawn here to f4
and then we could see a ton of different
stuff I've seen black try all sorts of
stuff from here you may see Knight to f6
attacking the Queen well we're just
going to go ahead and take this Knight
right here it's protected and then you
know after the King moves we're going to
take this bishop that's going to be fine
on board we could instead see Knight to
f7 that's fine as well we're going to
just go ahead and take this material
right here you know if we receive pawn
here to d6 then we just continue the
aggression Queen here to c4 check that's
going to be fine as well we could always
see pawn to g6 same thing as before go
ahead and take the night here on e5 now
we could see some very tricky stuff we
could see Knight to f3 check and this
kind of forces us to play pawn to you
know taking here on f3 we could see pawn
here to d6 protecting this Bishop here
on c5 then we can always play pawn to d4
it's kind of tricky we're kind of
recognized the bishop can't take here on
d4 because Queen to d5 check and then
the bishops going to fall but it's also
tricky because the bishop can't really
come here to b4 because now after your
pawn to d3 or c3 usually the bishop just
comes back here to a5 it's kind of a
safe move but now the Queen can just
take so this is not only
forcing the bishop back but it's
controlling the center of the board and
then the Queen can usually come in here
to d5 if he wants to f5 depending on
where as opponent goes you can always
get his knight involvement to the game
and also it's opening up the door for
the dark square bishop also we now have
the G file semi open file for the rook
to control so while this is very crazy
and the King is not safe that's kind of
the name of the game now the best move
from black if we look at it instead of
the knight coming down here is just to
play pawn to d6 now we can still take
this knight get some material back but
this kind of opens up the door for the
LightSquared bishop so from here we're
going to go ahead and take after the
pawn recaptures we're going to come down
here to h3 this is just kind of one of
those hey your opponent's playing the
best moves you just have to hope that
they make a mistake so from here we're
kind of hoping for King to f6 we kind of
wrap our rook over here to f1 that's
kind of what we're hoping for now if we
see King to e7 then Queen to g3
hopefully they're kind of looking at
this g7 square they make a mistake and
they play you know pawn to g6 then all
of a sudden that's a mistake Queen here
to e5 check we're going to go ahead and
take that rook over here on h8 as we
talked about this really requires a
mistake if we've come down this farm
more than likely they kind of know
what's going on but hey they could make
a mistake later on in the game like this
the next move that you could see from
here is King to f8 we're going to go
ahead and just take this night here on
e5 up you know you could see a dumb move
from here Knight to f6 or something who
knows really what they're doing just go
ahead and take the bishop don't get too
creative or anything but usually they're
going to play the most intuitive move
and that is pawn to d6 it opens up the
door for the light square bishop it
attacks the Queen it protects the bishop
this makes sense so I'm just going to
play Queen here to f4 check continue
that pressure they play Knight here to
f6 I'm going to play pawn here to d3
open up the board from light square for
my darks for a bishop I'm not going to
feel great about it though
I don't really like this position I'm
hoping that he doesn't play this he's
kind of opening up the door for all of
his pieces to get involved into the
action so this is this is not great
instead let's say he doesn't play Knight
to f6
he plays Queen to f6 okay also not a
great spot I'm gonna go ahead and take
right here after the Knight takes I'm
gonna go in and play Knight to c3 if we
look at on board he's got an extra minor
piece I've got two pawns up a material
his King is exposed you can't castle but
I don't have a queen so that's not as
important I'm definitely down the
material so I'm just going to fight back
here I don't want to get too crazy or
the game will just get away from me so
that's kind of a bad spot hopefully you
don't see that as well so we took a look
at if you actually get into the Joko
piano but sometimes your opinion your
opponent may not play that they could
try something crazy I've seen the
Blackburn shilling gambit which is
Knight here to d4 and they're kind of
expecting you just to play Knight taking
here on e5 oh hey there's free material
here but it's kind of nice when they
play this they feel like they're
creative and then you play Bishop here
to f7 and they're like I don't even know
what just happened this is bad after
they take you take with your knight
right here and then things just go very
bad they could play you know after the
King comes back here to e8 then we come
Queen to h5 they have you know two
options here if they're to play queen or
king to e7 then all of a sudden we see
check the Kings is going to come out all
of a sudden check we kind of force them
down the side of the board more checks
than all of a sudden we have checkmate
on board the only other really option
they have is if they were to play pawn
to we come back one more pawn to g6 and
then we're going to take here on g6
they're going to take we're going to
recapture here with our King our with
our Queen here on g6 and this just gets
crazy all their pawns on the Kings side
of the board are gone we've given up
material so we're definitely down in
that department but we're going to have
a fun time chasing this King around the
board so that's definitely one
option that would come back here instead
of the king coming back here to e8 if
you were to play King here to e6 then we
could just be pretty creative pawn here
to c3 if he wants to take we can
recapture his King's going to be in this
area of the board although we're down a
material right now we're controlling the
center with our pawns
we're going to be chasing as King all
over the board the rest of the game so
this is going to be fine as well and
that's kind of just a surprise you don't
have to play that against the you know
the the Blackburn shilling some people
kind of have their own flavor room how
they want to attack that but it's just
nice to have kind of the drôme gambit in
the back of your your mind knowing that
hey you can can blast this off
especially if it's a Blitzer a rapid
game it's just so hard for your opponent
to play this so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this fun gambit test it out let
me know what you guys think let me know
if you're having success with it until
next time hopefully you guys enjoyed and
I'll see you all in the next video
thanks for watching